Paul thanks for joining us good morning
give me the must-win situation this
weekend I think it's Bob Stoops in
Oklahoma he a Lawson suddenly you'll
hear people say if he will be doing a
good job even though he was in the
playoffs last year that's the problem
with being the head coach at Oklahoma
and he's been 24 pcs championships and
he was in the semi-finals but sooner
fans are anxious for another title and
without a win over urban meyer tomorrow
night they'll have to wait another year
is that him I mean I I don't look at
Oklahoma as a high pressure or the
highest of pressures but I don't know to
correct me if I'm wrong is there is
there more pressure there than any other
place interesting last year going into
last season he was under pressure and he
turned it around with the Baker Mayfield
Sonny I think that's I'm talking more in
terms of this season I mean they're
funnier you know I think health in the
Southern Cal better hope he doesn't get
blown out by Stanford because you know
as an interim coach in as a head coach
the 53 26 lost Alabam it wasn't really a
good look for him in his first his first
game is the full time head coach well
you would be right down ya se has been
known to fire coach is pretty quickly
yeah sometimes at the airport sometimes
they're sometimes that alumni function
Paul but are we just hoping USC is back
that that may be there I mean you can't
put them in the top 25 to start the year
I know that we do it it's almost like a
blanket stamp of approval but it feels
like college football's rooting for USC
to be back in the picture but they're
not now they're not and I get tired this
cliche you've heard it boy football
coach football certainly a lot better
when Michigan is good who cares I mean
they're plenty of there plenty of
schools to go around just ask Tom Herman
at Houston but I was surprised last week
two weeks ago excuse me when I started
hearing everyone make a case for SC
against Alabama and I just didn't see it
yeah they have good players across the
field they just don't have enough
to them how album it's not so much the
players on the field that makes Alabama
so girders the backups they could start
for SC in those positions so I mean I
don't think they're back and I think
after Stanford besom tomorrow night
they'll be vying with the Rams for the
worst team in LA although they actually
will not win that award Saban and Kiffin
in that exchange on the sideline what
would lead Nick to be that upset in that
game to yell at Lane Kiffin in front of
everybody well he looks obvious Kiffin
took a chance on on that play which
turned into a fumble but but Alabama was
bleeding at the time look 38 the 3am if
you want to play around with something
isn't that a pretty good time to do it
he just did not like the fumble and he
didn't like giving up the touchdown and
what I really don't understand and i
think you know i'm i'm right there as
co-chairman of the Nick Saban fan club
but he could have blown it off after the
game and when he was asked about the
conversation he said that wasn't a
conversation that was an ass-chewing you
know I mean it's great theater uh but it
it really came out to me is being
arrogant and a bully and I don't know
Nick Saban really needs that and then
last night on his radio show he he went
even went even deeper he's away I need
you know my coaches and players to be
obedient I mean is this guy the Sultan
of the of Brunei I mean I used to head
coach at Alabama and I just don't don't
think he needs to treat people even
though I thought it was interesting
someone said to me Nick Saban has done
something no one else in America has
ever accomplished that's mail it Lane
Kiffin into a sympathetic figure I think
being the head coach at Alabama is more
important than the Sultan of Brunei
though I think more pressure there just
to be on the red when it starts paying
more though it might be close though
where's Lane Kiffin hey where's Lane in
a year I think he'll be a head coach
somewhere now don't pin me down please
but there will be a number of openings
his name gets linked to any any
anyplace where there's an angry fan base
which is about half of the schools he
served his sentence and I think another
thing and he he was married he's no
longer married and I think being
divorced maybe one of the few times in
American history that being divorced
helps you get a job on a college campus
because I think he's eliminated that
issue from his job interview and I think
he needed to and I don't know why
someone won't take a chance I know that
I was fairly critical timid SC just like
everyone else but he he is the best
authentic ordinary i have seen in a long
time and i really don't believe Alabama
would have won the title last year
without his play-calling know we
explained about being divorced on a
college campus okay and how that helps
him I knew I knew I walked into that
then kippen was was living apart from
his wife she was still in LA and he was
in Tuscaloosa and there were stories web
stories you name it discussing that I'll
try to keep this clean and I but linking
him with nefarious activities is that is
that ok for ya morning radio and
television so he was hurting on the
internet or Twitter or was he dating
people you name it it was different he
was accused of doing it whether he was
really doing it or not i think is
debatable but i think when the divorce
went through it it eliminated that from
the conversation so as a divorce man
he's an easier hired by the way i'm sure
a lot of people will challenge that
assertion that's that's quite all right
he's Paul Finebaum from the mothership
sec nation will be live from Ole Miss on
saturday at ten a.m. michigan state
notre dame is this a must-win for Notre
Dame you mentioned Oklahoma had be
must-win situation what about Notre Dame
yeah I'm like 50 years ago damn they
can't go for the tie that was for
elderly people out there not so much
your young person but three people in
America got that joke thank you
or two of them they have to yeah we are
they have to win this game because you
know you know as great as Notre Dame is
they are not making the playoff with two
losses and last year they had narrow
mrs. they can't afford this i I don't I
don't think they're going to lose by the
way but I appreciate the question anyone
should since I think Notre Dame is
really good oh I do now that they've
settled on their quarterback and I think
yeah he's think he's a really good
quarterback and they got some skilled
position players comes down to you know
come a defense be a stout defense when
you need to I just look at Michigan
State as as maybe the most underrated
program in college football in the last
since you know Dantonio has been there I
mean it's pretty incredible that ohio
state gets the attention wisconsin gets
more attention now michigan gets more
attention and michigan state has been a
great great program yeah i agree with
you there they were in the playoffs last
year they won a couple of big ten's and
you know I think Harbaugh and Dantonio
could walk down the street and most
people would think Dantonio was like his
security guard nu uh I mean it's I i
I've not seen anything quite like Jim
Harbaugh sucking the the air and the
oxygen out of that state that other that
other school but I having said all that
I still don't think they're good enough
for this game but they are they are an
incredible program and I thought they
had a great year lashes Oh Alabama
steamrolled them forty eight to nothing
should Central Michigan consider giving
that win back to Oklahoma State no I
mean I don't think in my mind they
really didn't win the game but you know
what are you supposed to do wrap wrap it
in a you know in a package and FedEx it
to my gun DS office I mean I have you
get back a game welcome you could I mean
you could say we don't feel like we
deserved it but they did have a pretty
incredible play at that yet I mean to me
that the mistake there Dan was was from
the big 12 I mean this is a conference
too busy sending out feelers to high
schools in Pennsylvania for
future expansion okay and i don't know
why they I mean they they have a crew in
a room in Dallas at the officiating
official supervisors who watch all these
games and this wasn't a game opposite
nine other games it was like the eleven
o'clock game it was the only game going
but obviously someone was asleep or out
getting a another bag of Doritos when
they should have signaled immediately to
that stadium and get and gotten
attention on the sidelines too just to
protest my gun d.i.b yeah I mean he took
some responsibility but he does have a
few other things going on as opposed to
checking his rule book in his back
pocket well I think it starts with the
officials and Dan Gundy mammy I think
it's the officials and then Gundy but
nobody knew the rule and that's why you
know when it was brought up that a
central michigan should give that back
no no they they shouldn't I'm fine with
them not being sportsman of the year or
winning an SP yeah they will not win the
author actual well not but if they gave
the win back they could be sportsman of
the year I understand that but I I don't
put any fault I don't put the onus on
Central Michigan to do the right thing
the right thing was to get the rule
right then you wouldn't have given
Central Michigan the opportunity to have
that whim tell everybody we settle oh
and I mean everybody at Ole Miss if you
could go around yeah it will be fairly
disappointing this year I remember I
talked to you last year Katy Perry stole
the show and it's going to be a Grove
without Katy Perry the morning won't be
the same mr. years ago all right when
you saw her were you nervous yeah you
said she was holding our corn dog you'll
remember that and we'll leave you with
that yes thank you Paul right there hi
bud Paul Finebaum college gameday the
Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience
you